president Trump announces a precipitous
Syria pullout the Trump wall remains
mythical and we explore whether
feminists will allow girls to be girls
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
oh man we do have a lot to get to today
the president has been busy and not in a
particularly good way unfortunately
we'll get to all of that in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that you are going to die I know happy
holiday talk it's right before the
holidays you're in a good one then I
remind you that you're gonna plotz one
day but this is why you should not have
to think about life insurance or
plotting in the near future you should
go over to policy genius right now you
should pause whatever you're doing go
over to policy genius and then go check
out life insurance in minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers to find
the coverage you need at a price you can
afford from there you can apply online
and the unbiased advisors a policy
genius will handle all the red tape
leaving you free to do the things you
actually enjoy like not thinking about
death and life insurance and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy whether you are shopping for
disability insurance to protect your
income or homeowners insurance or auto
insurance they can help you get covered
fast if you've been intimidated or
frustrated by insurance in the past give
policy genius a try just go to policy
genius com to get your quotes in a 5
minutes you can do the entire thing on
your phone write this variance 10 code
of policy genius again the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance it is the
responsible thing to do if you got a
family if you have life costs if you're
an earner in your family you want to
make sure that your family is taken care
of go check it out right now policy
genius com to get your quotes and apply
in minutes go check it out alright so
the President's agenda is collapsing in
the last month of the year there's
really no nice way to put this the
President's agenda in the last week has
been just awful it has it's just been
awful I mean everything he has done has
been something the you would of expected
from the Obama administration not
something that you would have expected
from the Trump administration so as you
know I was luke cold on a criminal
justice reform from the very beginning I
remain Lukic old on criminal justice
reform maybe it'll work out maybe it
won't it should not have been a top
Republican priority to rewrite the law
to give people greater discretion to let
violent criminals and non violent
criminals out of prison if you want to
rewrite the laws in congressional
fashion so we actually lower the
penalties for particular crimes go ahead
and do that but simply getting rid of
mandatory minimums or ensuring that
wardens can let people out of jail if
they deem them to be nonviolent I have
some real problems with that
ideologically even though I like a lot
of the people who sponsor the bill and
and our appreciators the bill but that
is the least of president Trump's
concerns this week I mean and other
minor concerns the president ends not
minor the President issued an executive
order banning bump stocks now as you
know
said on the program I'm in favor of
banning bum stocks that does not mean
the president has the power under the
Constitution of the United States to
simply issue an executive order getting
rid of bump stock see new piece of
legislation to do that so if you want to
be asked a piece of bipartisan
legislation to make that happen he
certainly could he certainly could have
made that happen
he did not instead he did it from the
presidency itself from the executive
branch and just wait until Democrats
start trying to do the same thing
issuing executive orders to curb the
second amendment in minor or major ways
from the seat of government in the White
House I do not think that that is good
policy but again even that is the least
of our concerns today we begin with the
border wall so president Trump today
basically went back and forth and back
and forth and back and forth about
whether he was going to sign a bill that
would allow funding for the border wall
this is bad policy the reason it's bad
policy is because the president has been
wildly inconsistent on what exactly he
would sign he has spent two years not
holding the line on the funding for the
border wall he kept saying oh we'll kick
it down the road oh we'll kick it down
the road and then suddenly when the
right started yelling at him because he
was about to sign yet another continuing
resolution that did not include funding
for the border wall suddenly president
Trump woke up and started tweeting about
it this morning
government by tweet is not how
government gets done government by tweet
is not how legislation gets done if
President Trump is really a deal maker
you should have gotten everybody in a
room and you should have said listen
what do I need to give up to get what I
want instead president Trump basically
sits there any tweets and his members of
Congress and then he says that he's okay
with a continuing resolution a clean
continuing resolution so the Senate
passes one and then it goes to the house
and the house is ready to pass one and
then after there's blowback for
president Trump not vetoing such a bill
then he starts tweeting about it and
then members of the house start having
second thoughts and then they feel like
they have to vote on a bill that would
include five billion dollars in border
funding and then that will probably fail
and then the president will sign the
continuing resolution anyway whereas if
you just held the line from the very
beginning there's a better shot that at
least people are incentivized to do what
he wants president Trump went on on a
bit of a Twitter bender this morning and
last night in which he's very upset that
people are angry at him a lot of his
allies are angry at him people like Ann
Coulter are very angry at him and
Coulter came out yesterday and she said
she will not vote for President Trump
without the wall he promptly unfollowed
her on Twitter so here is an Coulter one
of the earliest Trump boosters the
author of in Trump We Trust which is an
amazing
because again that's suppose we God not
Trump no matter what you think it's rum
guys should not be replaced with Trump
in any sentence at all but here's Ann
Coulter talking about how not voting for
she would not vote for Trump without the
wall and let me ask you this then Ann
Coulter January the November the second
Tuesday after the first Monday in
November 2020 comes along and there's
exactly as much wall built that day as
there is today does Anne Coulter vote
for Donald Trump for reelection no nor
will I think most of his supporters why
would we do so he's not the oh she's not
the only one who has been saying this
Laura Ingraham has been incredibly
critical I was critical yesterday on the
show Mark Levin was very critical
yesterday on his show rush limbaugh is
very critical he said that Trump
basically got ruled by the Democrats on
the wall Trump gets nothing and the
Democrats get everything including
control of the house in a few short
weeks in fact I just don't lose it this
Trump is gonna get less than nothing
because this compromise strips out the
1.6 billion dollars for the wall that
the Senate Appropriations Committee and
already approved weeks ago that's gone
to hay and this has caused Republicans
in the house to actually say okay well
let's get together and let's fight for
well mark meadows who was once
considered a possibility for the
president's chief of staff got up
yesterday and he said listen we made a
promise that we were gonna build this
damn thing so let's build the damn thing
is it actually gonna get built under
President Trump the answer is in all
likelihood no but here was Mark Meadows
yesterday making the case as I close out
this particular special order I think
it's appropriate for us to remind the
American people that there is a bad case
of Potomac fever up here in Washington
DC they forget what they promised the
American people and yet what they must
do is not forget this time mr. president
we're going to back you up if you veto
this bill we'll be there but more
importantly the American people will be
there okay so here's the part that I
find intellectually dishonest about a
lot of the debate that's going on right
now President Trump is supposed to be a
strong negotiator President Trump is the
one who's supposed to be standing behind
his own promises it was President Trump
who promised a wall that Mexico is going
to pay for approximately 1 million two
hundred seventy three thousand three
hundred and ninety three
times during the campaign and in the
aftermath it was President Trump who's
pushing that as a policy everyone who
said listen we don't need a wall we just
need more border security
all those people were considered cucks
all those people were considered
sellouts it was President Trump was
saying we need a wall and people like me
agreed with him on that point and we
need some sort of physical barrier along
the border just like Israel has a
physical barrier against terrorism in
the Gaza Strip
or in parts of Judea and Samaria we all
agreed with that and then President
Trump basically backed off of it hey we
have this this weird case where
everybody is so afraid of alienating
President Trump that they feel like they
have to kiss his ass routinely
they they have to do this routine where
if President Trump comes up short it's
everybody else's fault for coming up
short it's the great leader is never
wrong it's all the people around the
great leader who are somehow wrong but
let's face this okay Democrats are
celebrating today and they were
celebrating yesterday because they think
they rolled president from Nancy Pelosi
was literally dancing her cares away at
a Christmas party last night because she
knows that she is beating president
Trump at his own game in all of this if
you can't see this it's actually Nancy
Pelosi doddering old Nancy Pelosi
shuffling around - bye bye miss American
Pie which was written you know solid 73
years after she was born so good for her
that she's still capable of moving she's
dancing at a Christmas party last night
Seth Meyers because all of our
late-night comedy must be dominated by
politics he was mocking president Trump
yesterday for not getting the wall you
can see Democrats are very excited about
this they feel like Trump got played
Trump wanted five billion dollars for a
pointless border wall to enforce his
racist immigration policies but he was
too incompetent to figure out how to get
it the only way Trump's never gonna get
that wall as if he builds it with the
portraits he bought with his charity
money haha chums charity a scam that is
now falling apart one Trump associate
after another is pleading guilty to
federal crimes if all these lawsuits
work out Trump might have to go live in
the YMCA okay so all of this is stupid
from the left but this is why president
from now should never have caved on any
of this and this kind of last minute
hemming and hawing this this hole okay
well now I watched Fox News and now I'm
changing my opinion back on the wall
dude this is not the sign of a good
negotiator hey read the art of video
okay they're really this sort of
unpredictability this sort of random
changing of your own position all the
time it doesn't give your congressional
supporters anywhere to go
they feel like you might undercut them
one day you might actually be angry at
them for backing your own agenda I've
taken I've fielded calls remember of
members of Congress over the last two
years who have been utterly bewildered
as to where Trump even wants them to be
on particular issues especially about
the border they say well am I supposed
to vote for this for my not supposed to
vote for this because Trump will come
out and endorse the CR and then
everybody like okay well I guess I'll
vote for it and then Trump will
immediately undermine the same CR
there's a there is a a tweet today from
a journalist saying that a member of
Congress Republican member of Congress
said they weren't going to vote for the
CR until they got a tweet from the
president so we're now waiting for the
president to tweet about things before
we know how to vote on things promises
that he himself has been making for
years on end I mean listen to the
inconsistency in president Trump's own
Twitter feed he says the Democrats who
knows steals lats AWOL are necessary for
border security are putting politics
over country what they are just
beginning to realize is that I will not
sign any of their legislation including
infrastructure unless it has a perfect
border security USA wins okay all of
that is fine if that had been a
consistent position but within the next
tweet okayyyy tweets separated by
minutes
president Trump writes this with so much
talk about the wall people are losing
sight of the great job being done on our
southern border by border patrol ice in
our great military remember the caravans
well they didn't get through and none
are forming around their way border is
tight fake news silent so which is it do
we need a wall do we not need a wall who
the hell knows right according to
President Trump the one who was pitching
the wall from the outset it depends on
his bowel movements that day apparently
a president Trump then tweeted out when
I begrudgingly sitting that now he's
trying to blame Paul Ryan of course
after sending all of these mixed signals
and coming to some sort of agreement
with Republican leadership now he's
backing out of it which means that again
the house will probably pass some sort
of bill or try to pass a bill with
border funding it'll fail and then
they'll pass a clean CR and then Trump
will sign the clean CR and that's how
this is probably gonna go president
Trump says when I begrudgingly signed
the omnibus bill
I was promised the wall in border
security by leadership would be done by
the end of the year now it didn't happen
we foolishly fight for border security
for other countries but not for our
beloved USA not good again I agree with
his position on border security but does
he agree with his position on border
security and why in the world this is
the guy who says that Washington is
corrupt Washington is a swamp Washington
is full of liars so why did you buy the
promises
earlier this year doesn't that make you
a fool doesn't it make you foolish to
buy the promises that were made by
legislators that were never going to be
kept or is it possible you knew all
along that these promises we're not
gonna be kept you went along with it at
the time and now you're fussing and
blaming everybody else when it turns out
that you're not capable of keeping a
promise that you made to the American
people answer your own supporters no I
don't I don't want to be this critical
of the President of the United States
but it is his job to get this stuff done
this is his number-one promise I'm gonna
get two promises that he's made in just
a second because I keep hearing about
all these promises that he's kept his
President of the United States he has
kept many promises as president of the
United States there are a few key ones
he is not keeping and those are coming
back to bite him this week we get to
that in just a second first we need to
talk about your capacity to sleep well
so I know that you've gotten the best
mattresses on the market which I'm sure
you've heard about on this show I am
sure that you have made sure that all
your air is fresh because you have the
best air filters which you have heard
about on the show but the real question
is do you also have the best sheets on
the market we're never going to agree on
everything but everyone should be able
to agree you need a better night's sleep
and sheet quality does matter I mean
people think that okay I'm just gonna go
down get the highest thread count
everything will be great
that's not how any of this works you
need an actual great comfortable pair of
sheets and the way that you can do that
is go to bowl and branch everything they
make from bedding to blankets is made
from pure 100% organic cotton which
means they start out super soft they get
even softer over time you buy directly
from them so you're essentially paying
wholesale prices luxury sheets can cost
up to a thousand bucks in the store bow
and branch eats are only a couple of
hundred bucks even three u.s. presidents
sleep on ball and bran sheets I love my
ball and bran sheets they are so good
that when we got Boleyn Branch we
actually threw out all the other sheets
we owned because it kind of ruined
sheets for us it was the only sheet we
could actually sleep on sleeping is free
you can try bowl and bran sheets for 30
nights if you don't love them send them
back for a refund so this is risk free
stuff to get you started right now my
listeners can get 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets at bull and branch
comp remote code Ben that's bull and
branch calm promo code Ben 50 bucks off
your first set of sheets bol and branch
calm promo code Ben go check it out
right now
okay so the presidents of the United
States made a promise about the wall he
also made a promise that who's gonna
defund Planned Parenthood have the
Republicans made a move to defund
Planned Parenthood like any move I
thought that was a key promise of the
Trump administration we've had Congress
Republicans have now controlled the
House of Representatives they controlled
it continuous
from 2010 to 2014 ass abortion clinic
Planned Parenthood it had control
they've controlled Congress from 2010 to
2011 bill is funded Obamacare every
single appropriations bill has failed to
fund a border wall every single
appropriations bill has funded all of
the Democratic priorities if this is a
failure of government and when the
president is the president at least the
house could say okay Obama's not going
to sign anything that work with that we
passed so we have to pass something or
the entire government shuts down when
you run the Congress and the president
is the president don't you have an
obligation to at least try don't you
have an obligate doesn't President Trump
have an obligation to get into a room
with Republicans and maybe some
Democrats and try and cut a deal isn't
this something the president ought to be
trying to do as opposed to sitting there
and tweeting he's the great deal maker
so make a great deal now listen I'm not
sanguine about the fact that Democrats
are radically intransigent on the wall
they are of course but the president
also has the bully pulpit the president
has the capacity to go out and rip on
the Democrats willingness to expose
America to insecurity simply because of
their own arrogance and multicultural
nonsense President Trump could do that
every single day has he done that no
he's gone to campaign rallies and he
said the same stuff over and over but
has he made a national address to the
nation about the necessity for a border
wall has he used the power of the
presidency to push for stuff he has not
and then we're surprised when the
promise doesn't get kept this is it's
just not good stuff it's not good stuff
from the presidents of the United States
I'm disappointed a lot of his supporters
are disappointed about the wall and
again I'm not gonna blame that on the
Senate when he told the Senate to go
ahead and and make all of this happen
with without border funding it's really
it's so what's happening right the
second is that a bunch of people are
going to the White House to meet with
the president apparently it's Paul Ryan
and Kevin McCarthy and Mark meadows and
Jim Jordan they're also going to the
White House to to try and negotiate with
the president over all of this and what
they are basically saying now is that
maybe they're going to kind of deal with
the Democrats where the Democrats agreed
to wall money and the the White House
and GOP fund the Gateway tunnel which is
obviously a big project for New York
Democrats we'll see if this is some
that if that happens then good I mean
but that's not gonna happen
Democrats are not going to to make that
sort of a deal okay well we'll get two
more failures in just one second
apparently senator Sanders is now saying
the president is having a meeting with
Republican House members at noon today
at this moment the president does not
want to go further without border
security which includes steel slats or a
wall the president is continuing to
weigh his options so we'll see how this
plays out the president should stand
strong even if it's belated okay
meanwhile the president was involved in
a giant giant fail today with regard to
with regard to Syria okay his Syria
policy is just a disaster area the
president said yesterday that he was
going to pull out of the pull out pull
american troops out of syria and then he
went on his twitter and he issued a
statement about it the statement that he
issued is i mean frankly this is just
it's egregious so he says getting out of
syria was no surprise i've been
campaigning on it for years and six
months ago when i very publicly wanted
to do it i agreed to stay longer russia
iran syria and others are the local
enemy of Isis we were there we were
doing their work spelling their
incorrectly time to come home and
rebuild hashtag mega hey well actually
Russia around in Syria are not the local
enemy of Isis they've used Isis as a
rationale for upping their troop
presence in Syria they have no interest
in actually getting rid of Isis it
provides them the International excuse
for being there and pursuing their own
priorities there everyone
who knows anything about Syria
understands this the Turks have been
telling the United States to get out of
serious thing going and murder the Kurds
honestly if I'm if I'm Kurdish I'm
wondering how many times can I just get
screwed by the United States George HW
Bush promised then we were not going to
abandon the Kurds to the whims of Saddam
Hussein and we promptly abandon the
Kurds to the whims of Saddam Hussein the
Clinton administration promised the same
nothing happened to protect the Kurds
the Bush administration promised that we
were going to protect the Kurds in Iraq
and then there was a precipitous pullout
by Barack Obama
they left the Kurds in the middle of
nowhere basically and now the Trump
administration had promised solidarity
with the cards and they're pulling out
so that the Turks can go in and
slaughter the Kurds like if you're the
Kurds at this point you just got to
think who the hell am I supposed to
trust out here so we're pulling out and
to pretend by the way that this pullout
is militarily beneficial to the United
States is asinine as I mentioned
yesterday having a couple thousand
troops in
yuria to at least maintain status quo
makes a lot of sense and for folks at
well you know why don't we just pull out
and hand it over that vacuum is filled
by somebody so it'll be filled by Iran
okay so Iran will fill the gap and now
you'll have more missiles flowing into
Syria leading to the possibility of a
serious conflict Gration with its
neighbors Jordan in Israel or you will
see more mass slaughter by the Assad
regime leading to mass emigration into
Europe which will change the face of
politics over there and lead presumably
to the possibility of further terrorism
in Europe itself because sometimes
terrorists hide among the refugees right
or you'll see Turkey increase its sway
in the region turkey is a is a nasty
imperialist power at this point under
receive type erawan who's an Islamist
thug yeah all of this is just bad policy
and the president is making political
policy by tweet there's an article in
The Washington Post today it says in
April President Trump repeated his
campaign promise to end US military
involvement in Syria I want to get out
he said I want to bring our troops back
home in September senior administration
aides said at the time the president was
persuaded to change course some 2000 US
troops would stay in Syria indefinitely
not only until the Islamic state was
defeated but also until a political
solutions the overall Syria conflict was
in place and in a key part of Trump's
newly announced Tehran policy all
Iranian forces and their proxies aiding
Syrian President Bashar al Assad had
left the country on Wednesday Trump sent
head-spinning within his own government
and around the world by apparently
reversing himself again and by the way I
can tell you that folks in the White
House are confused about this his
decision was made on Tuesday according
to people familiar with the issue
following a small meeting attended only
by senior White House aides and
secretaries of defense and state most of
whom if not all sharply disagreed we
have defeated Isis in Syria my only
reason for being there during the trump
presidency Trump announced in a Twitter
post early the next morning stunned
defense and diplomatic officials were
left to confirm that Trump had ordered
the immediate withdrawal of all US
forces we are also apparently stopping
our air operations to protect the Kurds
according to officials in Reuters u.s.
President Donald Trump's orders withdraw
US troops from Syria also signifies an
end to the US air campaign against Isis
there US officials told Reuters on
Thursday speaking on condition of
anonymity an end to the US air war will
likely heightened fears that Isis which
has lost almost all the territory once
controlled
could be given space to regroup
and this notion by the way that Isis is
completely defeated is sure crap it's
just not true
the fact is that when John went when
Barack Obama idiotically undeclared Isis
the JV squad there were like seven
hundred members of Isis who promptly
took over half of rock right now there
are twenty to thirty thousand active
members of Isis in Iraq and Syria
according to Trump's own Pentagon
coalition officials say the numbers are
inflated but two other reports by the UN
and CSIS independently came up with
roughly the same estimation according to
Remini kalamaki
who's a correspondent for The New York
Times who covers Isis President Trump in
his own Twitter feed basically
acknowledged that Isis has not been
defeated saying that Russia or that
Russia and Iran and Turkey we're gonna
take on Isis now so they've been
defeated but they're still gonna be
fighting Isis you have to explain that
one well in just a second I'm gonna get
to president Trump's statements on Syria
he made a an open statement about Syria
that is really pretty egregious honestly
I'm sorry to be such a downer right
before the Christmas break but the news
is what the news is first let's talk
about your air quality around the
country millions of Americans are
turning up the furnace for the first
time and then spending a week freezing
at night why because they neglected to
change out their air filters and their
system failed this costly mistake is
completely avoidable by regularly
replacing the air filters and filter by
calm America's leading provider of HVAC
filters for homes and small businesses
you ever at home you try on your furnace
and you just start coughing because you
haven't gotten rid of those air filters
and you never thought about the air
filters until I reminded you right now
you should think about your air filters
well if you actually want to breathe
clean air in the middle of the winter
maybe you should think about changing
those air filters with HVAC filters from
filter by com you can choose from over
600 sizes including custom options that
ship free within 24 hours and for those
of you who like to kick the can down the
road
filter by will give you 5% off your
order when you subscribe for auto
replacement you'll never forget to
change your filters ever again this is
so much easier than going to the
hardware store having a special order
filters plus they work great they're
made in America we use filter by calm at
the Shapiro home we use it at the office
here at daily wire filter bite will save
you time and money and help you breathe
better that is filter bu Y comm again
filter by comm tell them that I sent you
tell them the Shapiro show sent you
filter by comm filter bu why calm
breathe cleaner air and save money be
and by the way they'll arrive on a
regular schedule if you order them that
way so go check them out right now
filter by comm so president from issues
a video yesterday on his Twitter feed
all about his policy
in Syria and here is what he had to say
fighting for a long time in Syria I've
been president for almost two years and
we've really stepped it up and we have
won against Isis we've beaten them and
we've beaten them badly we've taken back
the land and now it's time for our
troops to come back home so our boys are
young women our men they're all coming
back and they're coming back now we won
and that's the way we want it and that's
the way they want it okay then when he
says that that's the way they want it
and he points to heaven as though the
soldiers who were as though the soldiers
who served in Syria would definitely
back his policy this is something that
politicians are not allowed to do you're
not allowed to do this it was bad when
Obama did it it's bad when Trump does it
you don't get to say what the soldiers
really want is to come home I'm getting
letters from soldiers today I'm getting
letters from people who served in Syria
and they're saying we are abandoning our
Kurdish allies these are people who have
fought with us alongside us saving
American lives fighting next to us in
these places they're saying we are
abandoning this country we're abandoning
our mission not only are we abandoning
our mission we are actually exposing the
West to greater threat because as Isis
gains power they don't just stay there
how many Isis attacks have we seen in
the West over the past seven years since
Barack Obama finished his pullout from
Iraq and that it's just it's unseemly at
the very least to be suggesting to use
the authority of people who are dead to
back your own political program almost
no matter what the political program is
is unseemly at the very best and gross
at the very worst it's just again none
of this none of this holds none of this
hold the Syrian policy doesn't make any
sense there is no great demand to pull
2,000 troops out of Syria except by Rand
Paul who's an isolationist in the once
the situation has been solidified why
you would abandon that for Turkey is
beyond me and that's the other thing is
that there are reports today the
president Trump really did this in order
to appease the Turks that basically he
had a phone call with the Turks and the
Turks said you know what why don't you
withdraw and President was like you know
what why aren't I withdraw like that
that is unacceptable the Turkish
government is one of the worst actors in
the Middle East I know
a lot of bad actors in the release the
Turkish government is definitely one of
them the only potential upset in recent
days according to the Washington Post
was a threat by the Turkish president
received high up air Dhawan who spoke
with Trump at the group of twenty summit
three weeks ago and again on the
telephone Friday to send troops across
the border to attack the u.s. allied
Kurdish forces in Northeast Syria
officials with the fried familiar with
the Friday call said that Iran among
other things had stressed to trump that
the Syrian Kurds were terrorists allied
with Kurdish separatists in his own
country
and asked why the United States was
supporting them rather than its NATO
ally the answer is of course that turkey
never should have been part of NATO it
was a joke to make turkey part of NATO
it was never a westernized country and
the idea that we were going to bring
Turkey and to NATO and now make it they
make their defense are mutually
defensible position that if they are
attacked by the Kurds or something that
the United States has to get involve
it's amazing we're supposed to now worry
about Turkey as a NATO ally while we
don't worry about Latvia Estonia or
Lithuania as a NATO ally under Russian
threat it's unbelievable the apparently
the these are the ER de huaah noted that
the Islamic state had been vanquished
and questioned the need for an ongoing
US troop presence saying the Turkish
troops already massed on the Syrian
border could handle any problem there
apparently the call and the withdrawal
were definitely related according to
officials inside the White House this is
the only by the way ally of the United
States in the region that cares at all
that is happy at all about this decision
is Turkey and they are not really an
ally as I've already noted that an
Islamist country that has now arrested a
hundred thousand dissidents over the
last couple of years in a seizure of
power by air Dewan who is one of the
worst actors in the region Lindsey
Graham who's been a reliable trump ally
on foreign policy and nearly everything
else came out and ripped president Trump
yesterday the decision today by the
president and I think it was his alone I
think it's disastrous to our own
national security I am shocked by this I
think this is a decision that is against
sound military advice to say they're
defeated is an overstatement and is fake
news so what you have done in my view is
set us back so who's happy today Russia
is happy today Iran has happened today
Turkey is happening today you know he's
not happy today the Kurds Israelis
the Jordanians the Saudis the Egyptians
and basically all the allies that we
actually have those people are very
unhappy today all of the people who hate
the United States are pretty happy today
terrible move by President Trump I
understand he's trying to do an Obama
circle 2010-2011 he thinks he's gonna
win over people on the Left if he
withdraws from Syria it's not going to
happen that was a war that we were
actually winning if you're gonna talk
about withdrawing troops at least make
the argument about Afghanistan or
something like I think that there's a
better argument for Afghanistan than
there is for Syria although I don't
think there's a great argument for
either the minute we leave Afghanistan
the Taliban takes over and I'll Qaeda's
back but the this notion that you can
simply pull troops out willy-nilly from
places without any further consequences
is just ridiculous this has been the
constant lesson of the last 30 years
that doesn't mean you can ation build
every place it doesn't mean that we can
afford to put hundreds of thousands of
boots on the ground in all of these
places but if with a stable force of
2,000 people you can lock down these
areas and prevent Isis from becoming a
regional threat and an international
threat again that seems like a pretty
fair bargain to me and it's there's this
perspective about people who serve in
our military that they're sort of pawns
in the game of life and it's just stupid
you know these people say well you know
our poor our troops bring home the
troops have these people ever met troops
like really I spend a lot of time
talking with people who are in the
American military and not only because I
give a fair bit of money to American
military charities but also because we
have a lot of folks in the military who
listen to the show these people are not
joining up because they are desperate to
serve on a base in Georgia these people
are joining up because they want to
protect and defend the United States so
the question should not be what is the
safest place for our troops it should be
where our troops best utilized to keep
the American people safe and our troops
know that that's why they join up in the
first place to say less is to denigrate
their Patriot hasn't been joining up
then join up just for the the college
benefit our troops joined up because
they because they did something more
patriotic and I would do or most people
in my audience would do they joined up
because they want protect and defend the
United States understanding that we have
civilian control of the military here in
the United States and understanding the
threats to the United States are
ever-present remember is the military
I've talked to over the last 48 hours
think that this is cowardice they do and
it's in and I think that you know the
president's retreat on the international
stage is not restricted to Syria I mean
listen to this story today it's just a
very bad
week for news for the Trump
administration according to the
Associated Press North Korea said
Thursday it will never unilaterally give
up its nuclear weapons unless the United
States first removes what Pyongyang
called a nuclear threat which means what
they really want is for the United
States to remove all troops from the
Korean Peninsula which is never going to
happen the surprisingly blunt statement
jars with Seoul's rosier presentation of
the North Korean position that's because
Seoul South Korea has what we call a
sunshine government which is dedicated
to some sort of approach ma with the
North Korean government but that doesn't
mean the North Koreans are actually
attempting to make a deal I said this
when President Trump held his summit
with Kim jung-ho and I said either this
is the most brilliant diplomatic
maneuver or of all time or it's utterly
stupid and the North Koreans are the
North Koreans the Kim the the Kim regime
over there has been utterly consistent
in what they do they lie to the west
from for concessions and they go right
back to developing their nuclear weapons
the latest from North Korea comes as the
United States and North Korea struggle
over the sequencing of the
denuclearization that Washington wants
and the removal of international
sanctions desired by Pyongyang the
statement carried by the North's
official Korean Central News Agency also
raises credibility problems for the
liberal South Korean government in other
words just like Barack Obama made a huge
mistake in trusting the terrorists
regime in Iran so they'll keep their
promises there their moderating their
nice it turns out terrorist regimes
rogue regimes don't really have a habit
of doing that if they want to moderate
you know what they can always do they
can do a more market off you did before
we kill them right they can hand over
their nuclear weapons scot-free
nothing's stopping them from doing it
right now Iran if it wanted to join the
family of nations you know what it would
have to do just join the family of
Nations it's up if North Korea wanted to
join the family of Nations all they'd
have to do is join the family of Nations
nothing is stopping them say do we have
to negotiate for them to do the right
thing is insane its but we are we are we
or are we not the most powerful country
in the history of the world do we or do
we not have the most powerful military
in the history of the world are we or
are we not the most powerful economy in
the history of the world we're acting in
the Obama administration and we weren't
acting like that's under Trump and now
in the last week we are do we have
leverage or do we not right this is a
question with Saudi Arabia also when MBS
when Mohammed bin Salman had a Saudi
citizen killed and it became public and
then we acted as though we need the
Saudis more than the Saudis need us we
if
president Trump is a guy with swagger
right mean that that is his thing so why
not swagger on the world stage I didn't
mind that one I liked that about
President Trump I liked about George W
Bush by the way the United States ought
to have a little bit of swag around the
world stage why because our values are
superior to the values of North Korea or
Iran or Turkey or the Syrian government
or Saudi Arabia or or any other country
frankly doesn't mean we don't need
allies and it also means that we ought
to be using our leverage who are
appropriate but instead it seems like
what we're we're afraid to use our
leverage why do I say that because North
Korea is openly stating now they're not
going to denuclearize without the United
States leaving the Korean Peninsula the
statement says the United States must
now recognize the accurate meaning of
the denuclearization of the Korean
Peninsula and especially must study
geography when we talk about the Korean
Peninsula it includes the territory of
our Republic and also the entire region
of South Korea where the United States
has placed its invasive force including
nuclear weapons when we talk about the
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
it means the removal of all sources of
nuclear threat not only from the south
and north but also from areas
neighboring the Korean Peninsula meaning
they want us to remove our presence in
Japan and so that's what they want also
so what is the Trump administration's
response to all of this breaking this
morning u.s. hopes Kim Trump summit
could take place in early 2019 I don't
know what - honestly I don't know what
to say is is the motivating factor here
it makes no sense to me I think that it
cuts against everything that President
Trump has purported to be on foreign
policy so we've got the wall situation
following apart for him we've got the
Syrian situation falling apart from we
got the North Korean situation falling
apart from him what do all of these have
in common
president Trump builds himself as a man
who would not cave and what we have seen
in the past week is caving and caving
and caving and caving mr. president
stands strong these are things you
promised you promised to keep the
American people safe that promise means
more than a dumb promised to remove
troops at whim from a place in the world
where the troops were actually doing
some good and abandoning our allies in
the process you made a promise to build
the wall so build the wall all of this
is it's got to be maddening for for
Trump supporters it should be maddening
for Trump supporters and if not if
you're a trump supporter you should ask
yourself why you're not maddened are you
not Maddon because
we're so invested in President Trump
just as a person that we don't care what
he does politically or because we've
convinced ourselves that every choice is
a binary that we can't push president
Trump for better that every time
something President Trump does is wrong
or bad that we have to say ah but the
Democrats would be worse
the Democrats aren't in office right now
you know who is a guy named president
Trump
that means it's his job to do what he
said he was going to do I have a couple
more notes about this and then I do want
to get to the latest on the Trump legal
garage the the Muller investigation
coming after President Trump again very
bad week for the president we'll get to
all of that in just one second first go
over to Daly wire.com and subscribe for
$9.99 a month you can get a subscription
to daily wire when you do you get the
rest of this show live you get the rs200
Clavin show address and Michael knows
his show live he had to ask questions on
shows like the conversation that we had
yesterday which is really a lot of fun
also coming in January two additional
hours of the Ben Shapiro show happening
every single day and I think you will
enjoy it but you can only get that
behind the paywall if you are not
listening live on radio so go check that
out as well
we'll also be doing some fun stuff like
occasionally taking questions during the
actual radio show during the breaks so
we'll be doing all sorts of fun stuff in
the very near future go check that out
right now subscribed for $9.99 a month
for 99 bucks a year you get this your
very greatest in beverage vessels the
leftist yours hut or a cold tumbler I
know I need to sip it to cool down today
I'm a little bit hot today
but the good news is just as I hold this
the comb begins to flow through me once
again go check it out the leftist here's
hot or cold tumblr please subscribe over
at iTunes and YouTube please leave us a
review we always appreciate we're the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so another bad news for a president
Trump the Muller investigation is
continuing forth with Roger stone
apparently still under serious scrutiny
by the Muller Office now why does that
matter because the Muller investigation
has basically come up with its theory I
think and it's theory is that President
Trump was being funneled information via
a radio talk-show host to Jerome Corsi
to Roger stone to President Trump and so
now what they're trying to figure out is
whether Roger stone lied in his House
Intelligence Committee statements when
he suggested that President Trump was
never informed that WikiLeaks was going
to dump information about Hillary
Clinton and that WikiLeaks was a Russian
front group according to the Washington
Post Special Counsel Robert Muller asked
the House Intelligence Committee on
Friday for an official transcript of
Trump advisor Roger stones testimony
according to people familiar at the
request assigned the prosecutors could
be moving to charge him with a crime
it's the first time Muller has formally
asked the committee to turn over the
material the panel has gathered in its
investigation of Russian interference
legal analysts say that Muller may be
ready to indict him Roger stone says I
don't think any reasonable attorney who
looks at it would conclude that I
committed perjury which requires intent
and materiality okay well in the past
perjury charges have not always included
strong a stone is not completely wrong
on this but it is quite possible to what
Mullen is actually trying to do is
indict Roger stone for perjury and then
turn on President Trump and and then
turn on stone and say you're on Roger
you're gonna do 27 years in jail or
you're going to admit that President
Trump told you to lie to the House
Intelligence Committee and tell you to
suborn perjury
that's basically what the Starr
investigation did with Monica Lewinsky
to come up with suborning perjury charge
against President Bill Clinton back in
1998 and 1999 so we will see how the
Muller investigation goes about its
business in this area now meanwhile you
know it is amazing with the Republican
Party experiencing all of these
difficulties it's easy to forget the
Democratic Party has been engaged in
similar corruption worse corruption in
some cases and manipulation this is an
amazing story that basically the
Democrats were manipulating a race in
Georgia so here is the story from the
New York Times as Russia's online
election masa nations came to light last
year a group of Democratic tech experts
decided to try out similarly deceptive
tactics in the fiercely contested
Alabama Senate race according to people
familiar with the F
and report on its results so while the
Democrats are whining and the Russians
were putting up fake facebook pages with
fake news the Democrats were doing
exactly the same thing on Facebook and
Twitter in the Alabama Senate race that
Roy Moore ended up losing the secret
project according to the New York Times
carried on Facebook and Twitter was
likely too small to have had a
significant effect on the race in which
the Democratic candidate it was designed
to help Doug Jones edged out the
Republican Roy Moore but it was a sign
that the American political operatives
of both parties have paid close
attention to the Russian methods which
some fear may come through taint
elections in the United States well a
couple of things one this is an
overreach of Russia
hey trolling has been happening online
as long as I've been online this is
nothing new to look at how the New York
Times covers that right so when the
Democrats engage in deceptive activity
on Facebook and Twitter in an attempt to
suppress Republican votes in a
senatorial election then in the New York
Times notes that the secret project was
likely too small to have had a
significant effect on the race when the
Russians issue like a few facebook posts
that reach my new number of people I
read you the statistics the other day
then it swung the entire election don't
worry folks
there is no media bias at all at all
speaking of corruption we've been
hearing non-stop about corruption when
it comes to all of the Republican moves
in North Carolina's ninth congressional
districts the hiring of a particular
person who is known for sort of stuffing
ballot boxes now it turns out in that
investigation that person has worked for
both Democrats and Republicans was
working for Democrats in 2016 and nobody
seemed to care and I love that this
story is flying completely under the
radar but in California or a bunch of
late-breaking House races went for the
Democrats and everybody to know can't be
voter fraud that would be impossible
that would be impossible even though
California does have rules that allow
people to go and ballot gather meaning
go to people's houses and pick up their
absentee ballots for them the
possibilities of fraud are rife how rife
are they
according to the Sacramento Bee
California's Department of Motor
Vehicles confirmed on Monday that its
director gene Shia Miyamoto will retire
after three decades with the Department
and it's mullahs final year why exactly
is she is she resigning well she's
resigning because the department
struggled to implement new laws this
year including the state's motor voter
program which launched earlier this year
to automatically register people to vote
when they visit the DMV the Department
announced in September it had improperly
registered thousands of Californians
through the program
thousands of Californians were
registered improperly by the DMV under
state law in the state of California
fraud though we've been told voter fraud
is the only thing that happens when
Republicans suborn it but when Democrats
are involved in the possibility of voter
fraud when the laws make it easier to
commit voter fraud then we're crazy
we're trying to suppress the vote if we
mention all of these things the DMV has
also faced increased challenges with
issuing federally mandated real ID cards
which are required by October 1st 2020
for people who want to board airplanes
and enter other federal facilities
without a passport Secretary of State
Alex Padilla said last week she amido
had most lost my confidence and Trust
and called on Jerry Brown the Governor
of California and governor elect Gavin
Newsom to promptly appoint new
leadership at the DMV
so the DMV is just a crap show on the
state of California but more importantly
corruption does not only exist on one
side of the aisle despite what the media
would have you believe corruption
certainly exists on the left side of the
aisle when you mention this then
Democrats say that you're trying to
suppress votes if you mentioned that
voter fraud is a real thing and that
people can gather ballots like literally
just go door-to-door gathering ballots
and we don't know what happens between
the time those ballots are gathered and
the time those ballots reach their final
destination if you mention that it's
because you're trying to suppress votes
but if Republicans do the same thing in
North Carolina then obviously what
you're talking about is voter fraud
serious voter fraud if the Russians are
attempting to manipulate things via
Facebook pages it affects the entire
2016 election but if Democrats do the
same thing in Alabama in the middle of
an election in a senatorial election
then the effect is probably too small to
have swung the election how do we know
that well because the New York Times
says so you wonder why people don't
trust our institutions this is why
people don't Institute trust our
institutions of media they're they're
losing trust in voter integrity they're
losing trust in our in the function of
government because everybody makes
promises and no one keeps any of the
promises all of this should be deeply
disturbing to Americans who care about
the functioning of the federal and state
governments okay time for a couple of
things that I like and then we'll get to
some things that I hate so as I
mentioned earlier this week it's time
for some calming music after that show
so things I like this week Beethoven was
was born this week since-- paid Tom's
birthday that means that we're doing all
Beethoven all week this is one of my
favorite piano sonatas one of his it's
still famous but one of his lesser-known
famous piano sonatas have them
this is his piano sonata number 21 the
bald Steen sonata emile gallé owls again
on piano when my favorite pianists I
love this piece so much it is fantastic
this is the last movement of the
Beethoven piano sonata number 21 the
bald Steen sonata
[Music]
okay so I mean it's just did beautiful
music I love it um so go check that out
if you need to be combed a little bit
today because it really is good stuff
okay other things that I like so
whatever you think of speaker Paul Ryan
and I've not been supremely happy with
his performances speaker because I don't
know you know that there's ever been a
Speaker of the House that I'm fully
happy with it's a difficult job for sure
but Paul Ryan's farewell address was
very good yesterday so give his farewell
address on the floor of the Congress
he's obviously leaving his job whatever
you think of Paul Ryan his comments
about where we need to fix the country
are exactly right it is not inside
government this is what I've said
repeatedly it's the case that I make in
the right side of history my new book
that's coming out in March which you
should go check out at any bookseller
including Amazon Barnes & Noble any of
them go check out would go check it out
there it was it was the number one
trending book on Amazon yesterday so
thank you for that but everybody should
go pick it up it's great if I do say so
myself and I wrote it but Paul Ryan made
the case basically that our our focus on
Washington DC our focus on politics
ignores the fact that the country is
really built outside of government than
what we really need to focus on right
now is rebuilding the social fabric in
our neighborhood and our communities
that's the way that things are going to
get done not by relying on some great
god-king in Washington DC of either
party to magically fix your life here's
Paul Ryan talking about it and this is
part of the problem with being Speaker
of the House is as Speaker of the House
people are constantly berating you get
things done get things done when in
reality the congressional system was
built not to get things done and the
massive growth in government we've seen
over the last 80 years has been a
serious problem in in trying to walk
back it's almost impossible to walk back
or at least very difficult which is why
Paul Ryan who came in to office
promising entitlement reform expenses
entire career fighting for it and
failing here's Ryan though talking about
what really needs to happen in society
if we are to rebuild the level of trust
necessary for a functioning civilization
what a country where someone of an
unassuming Midwest upbringing gets a
chance to be a part of all of this what
a country you can pursue whatever your
passion is wherever it takes you I mean
that's the American idea isn't it
the condition of your birth isn't your
destiny your struggle isn't your destiny
it's part of your journey okay so you
know that sort of hope is good his
speech is very good again whatever you
think of Paul Ryan the message that we
all need to you know figure out our
community and that that's where that's
where real growth begins that of course
is exactly correct that's a conservative
position because what the left would
have you believe is that there are only
two modes of living one is as an
atomized individual and two is through
the great collective of government what
the right has always said is that the
actual way of living goes like this you
as an individual your family unit your
community your state and then finally
the federal government when it comes to
where you should be putting your trust
the last place you should be putting
your trust is in the federal government
okay time for some things that I hate
okay so the thing that I hate number one
so Jack Phillips of masterpiece cake
shop is just getting destroyed by the
state of Colorado it's disgusting so
there's some vindictive piece of garbage
human who has decided they're gonna go
into this Christian Baker shop and
they're going to ask him to bake every
offensive cake they can think of so
they've already asked him to bake a cake
for a same-sex wedding and he said no I
can't do that cuz I'm a Christian and
then they sued him and he lost hundreds
of thousands of dollars and then it went
all the way up to the Supreme Court and
the Supreme Court sort of said well he
gets to bake whatever cake that he wants
it's artistic expression but the the
ruling was very narrow so now they want
to drag him back into court because what
they want to say is that he's still
discriminating what the Supreme Court
kiss what the Supreme Court said in the
first case is that he's not allowed to
discriminate but the state of Colorado
also can't be discriminatory and how it
applies the rules and obviously they had
animus for this particular guy so what
the people who are going after Jack
Phillips now want to do is allow the the
state of Colorado to show no animus but
punish Jack Phillips so now they're
doing the same thing the same jerks are
coming back to Jack Phillips bakery and
now they're asking him to bake a gender
identity transition cake he's in he's a
religious Christian he says no I won't
do that so now the state of Colorado is
cracking down again on him again this is
honestly this is a fascist mindset you
got to make people do what they don't
want to do or they're bad people and
this is the local news reporting on it
Colorado Baker who won a victory in the
Supreme Court when he refused to bake a
cake for a gay couple on religious
grounds
a new legal battle on his hands the
Colorado Civil Rights Commission
recently ruled that Jack Phillips had
discriminated against a transgender
woman they say Phillips refused to bake
a cake for the woman who wanted one with
blue frosting and a pink interior
passion has made it clear that it is
intent on punishing Jack Phillips other
cake artists are allowed to decline
messages that they don't want to
communicate but when mr. Phillips does
it they come after him okay so the
problem here is not a double standard so
that I know that the lawyers are making
the case that it's a double standard
because that's how the Supreme Court
ruled the real problem here is no Baker
should be forced to make any cake they
don't want to bake for any purpose
hey that's what freedom is called I
don't believe the federal government or
the state government should be forcing
people to engage in business with people
they don't want to engage in business
with I know it's a controversial
position because people say okay what
about racists you don't want to serve
black people or what about anti-semites
you don't want to serve Jews and my
answer is go to a different bakery then
those people's businesses will fail
because people will rightly say I don't
want to shop at a cake shop that won't
serve black people or won't serve gay
people or world sort of Jewish people
okay this is where the free market comes
in freedom of choice involves allowing
people to choose to do things you don't
like and if you don't believe that then
you might want to re-examine your
assumptions about how wonderful you are
as a human because if somebody could
come along and try to force you to do
something that you don't like the sword
cuts both ways okay other things that I
hate today so there's a tweet that came
out yesterday and it was a picture of
Rachel McAdams so I don't want to rip on
the person who sent the tweet I want to
rip on first I think it's Vogue magazine
that said this I don't rip on the
photoshoot itself so it's a tweet of
Rachel McAdams in heavy makeup wearing
basically a sexy bra and then nursing
she's got breast pumps on both her boobs
and a lot of people are so look at the
feminism look at the feminism so a
couple of things first of all well I
think that breast milk is wonderful and
has certain medicinal advantages plenty
of babies grow up on formula plenty
women don't have time to pump and that
is not a rip on the parent so this kind
of virtues signaling with breast pumping
is really silly second of all breast
pumping in Versace like who does that
like this is that the statement you need
is a rich after it's a super-rich
actress who apparently sits around in
like random hotel lobbies breast pumping
while wearing Versace if I'm going to
talk about you know
heroism and breast pumping my wife Jane
who is a doctor it turns out would do
her it would pump for our second child
because she was so she was in medical
school and residency when she had our
kids respectively for for my son my wife
would pump in the closet at the hospital
between hospital shifts and so that's a
little more impressive and a little more
feminist than rachel mcadams who's
exorbitantly wealthy works reading other
people's wine sitting there wearing
makeup and like the virtues signaling
and breast pumping is just I'm sorry
it's tiring it's tiring my like I think
that women who do it are doing something
cool I think it's great there's a woman
at the office who breast pump and we
provide a space for them to do it I
think that that's wonderful but the
whole virtues signaling I'm better than
you because look at me I'm a feminist
because I breast pump all right whatever
man
I just know and I'm less than impressed
by the the Vogue virtue signaling of
she's fierce because she breast pumps
while wearing Versace you know I have a
lot more respect for women who who
breast pump and just don't make a big
fuss out of it like I have a lot of
respect for that that that seems to me
oh there's a lot of virtue signal or
virtue signaling around early motherhood
and pregnancy I see the same thing
sometimes with weather there's this
class of women who do this whole if
you're if you do natural birth right you
don't use an epidural you do natural
birth then this makes you a better
person say why why like experiencing
more pain makes you all this is just
silly talk okay so there's that as well
okay final thing that I hate today so
there's a tweet that somebody sent out
yesterday that is utterly insane okay
there's a picture of these migrant kids
these my grandkids have arrived at the
border in order to keep track of them
and so that people are not switching
they're switching their IDs the Border
Patrol has been writing numbers on their
arms well obviously this has this has
sort of echoes of the Nazis putting
numbers on people's arms right that's
the idea here
so some tweeted out about this and
suggested that the and they tweeted this
picture they said the only reason people
cared but I cared about the Holocaust is
because it had white victims a couple of
things about this one
the Jews were specifically
during the Holocaust because they were
not considered white by the prevailing
dominant culture at the time - these
kids are not going to be sent to gas
chambers with their entire families
murdered and cremated many of them will
become Asylum refugees in the United
States many of them will not but read
another book you know I said it's about
Harry Potter a lot people always do this
isn't this just like Harry Potter no
it's not just like Harry Potter you're
an idiot
okay well save read another book read
another book okay not everything is the
Holocaust it's not the Holocaust when
people come to the US border are made to
wait in line have in magic marker or
something written on there not a
permanent tattoo magic marker I've
written memoirs with Holocaust survivors
you know dismissive and derisive it is
to suggest this but this idiots tweet
this guy named into focal 'if you
tweeted I will say it again you all only
care about the Holocaust because the
victims were white 35,000 likes on
Twitter 17,000 retweets just idiotic
idiotic so garbage opinion dude but you
know I guess that that's the way we go
now everything is the Holocaust
everything is Hitler except for actual
Holocaust and Hitler that that's not
actual that's not actually bad I guess
and that's not as bad anyway all right
well we will be back here tomorrow I
hope that the news turns I hope that we
have much more great things to report to
you before we leave for our Christmas
vacation if not we'll be here anyway so
we'll see you then
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018